The days I am fasting should I take supplements some have to be taken with food
So remember fasting with cancer
Typically you don't want to fast more than 24 hours, but
Let's say you're doing a fast word. You're doing a time restricted eating you're not eating until
6 o'clock or something
So should I take my supplements in the morning? Well, there's two lines of thinking there so if the purpose of doing fasting is
I'm trying to lose weight. I don't want any caloric intake because I'm trying to lose weight
Then that that line of thinking that you don't take your supplements when you're fasting
I'm not trying to fast to lose weight. I'm just trying to fast to stimulate a topical
And to be healthy
Well, then I would take my supplements
The ones you have to take with food, then you will take them. You'll have to wait
So but otherwise I would take my if I was dealing what I was dealing with
My cancer when I was in bad shape. I
Was doing a lot of time restricted eating and I was doing a lot of fasting
But I was still taking all my cancer killing supplements
So I would I would still stay on that